sophie are you ready to begin
take me back
where were you before
[Music]
and before that
your job and before that
can you keep going
do you know what it feels like
to not remember anything
everyone keeps telling me who they think
i am it's a fresh start but if my life
was so perfect why did i try to end it
[Music]
sophie it's time to move forward but i
need to know what really happened we do
know no we think we know based on what
we think happened
what if i didn't jump
was there anything unusual about that
day
you were saying all kinds of crazy
things a man pushed you from the boat
your id said one name and you kept
insisting it with something else
people with perfect lives don't usually
jump off of fairies
day of the accident your husband's alibi
is a lie
if you're starting to remember some
things that must be really scary
sometimes it's hard not knowing your own
secrets
we can't just pretend we're new people
that the past doesn't exist
you really don't remember dude your
husband's not really thinking
why did you lie she's starting to ask
questions i can't answer maybe i was
wrong about everything
sophie what's going on
just
putting the pieces together
you